hallo klicksum hallo Johannes in deinem
Lied Engel singst du über Schutzengel
denn das dein Engel ist habe ich sofort
gewusst hat seine Flügel gut versteckt
damit die Welt ihn nicht entdeckt
meistens realisieren ja Menschen die in
extrem brenzliche Situationen kommen
dass es sowas wie eine höhere Macht oder
einen Schutzengel
gibt wann und wodurch bist du zu der
Erkenntnis gekommen dass es
Schutzengel gibt dem meine zweite Frage
geht sowohl an die Zuschauer als auch an
dich wenn sich dein Tag wie beim
untäglich grüß das
Murmeltier sich immer wiederholen würde
was würdest du als allererstes
machen ja danke für die Antworten und
bis dann zuersten
Frage ich glaube es war bei mir eher so
ein Tag wo
ich schlecht drauf war und wo ich dachte
mein Gott wieso geht's mir so schlecht
warum passiert mir immer komische Dinge
und ich war richtig mies gelau und dann
habe ich gedacht nee eigentlich darf man
so an die Sache nicht rangehen denn man
merkt sich immer nur die die schlechten
Dinge die einem passieren die merkt man
sich ein bisschen mehr als die
eigentlich guten Dinge und dann habe ich
mir einfach die ganzen guten Sachen die
mir passiert sind dass mir eigentlich ja
gut geht dass ich glücklich bin ins
Gedächtnis gerufen und und da wurde mir
sehr schnell klar dass auch viele Dinge
einfach passieren oder schöne Dinge
passieren weil eben andere Menschen auch
dafür sorgen indem sie vielleicht auch
mich aufpassen indem sie sich um mich
kümmern und mir helfen oder mir Liebe
geben und in dem Song Engel ist ist eben
der Engel ein Synonym für Menschen die
in meinem Umfeld sind das können
Partner Familienmitglieder Freunde sein
die einem eben
m s gewisse Sicherheit geben ein ja im
weitesten Sinne beschützen und dafür
sorgen dass man glücklich und beschützt
durch Leben geht das sind dann eben die
weltlichen
Schutzengel und zu deiner zweiten
Frage was mache
ich jeden Morgen jeden Tag aufs Neue es
ist ganz ganz klassisch ich stehe auf
und wander mit wachen nee überhaupt
nicht mit Wachen mit halbzen Augen durch
meine wohn und geh als allererstes zur
Kaffeemaschine leg hoffentlich einen
frischen Pet oben rein und ma mir
erstmal einen schönen starken Kaffee
damit überhaupt irgendwas passieren kann
an dem Tag manchmal habe ich Pech und
ich bin so verplant und stell nur die
Tasse drunter und Wechsel das Pad nicht
aus und dann kommt unten irgendwie so
eine abwasserplöre raus vom letzten
kalten Pad aber das merkt man dann auch
nach ein zweimal trinken das ist das was
ich jeden Morgen machen Kaffee Kaffee
Kaffee Kaffee ist wichtig fürs Herz und
für die Seele und damit man überhaupt
erstmal die Augen weiter als auf 7:30
aufkriegt